j'ai commencé le vélo pendant la période
de la covid parce que c'était un des
seuls sports permis pour moi c'est une
belle façon de méditer c'est une belle
façon aussi de visiter des places une
belle vitesse
dari crichtiouk est né en Ukraine et à
immigré à Lévy à l'âge de 10 ans
plusieurs de ses proches sont toujours
là bas il les a visités en 2018 la
mission que je me suis donné c'est
rebâtir les dégâts de guerre en Ukraine
en fait c'est je voulais une mission un
peu plus pacifique je voulais pas savoir
quelque chose qui encourage la violence
il part donc pour l'expédition de sa vie
parcourir d'ici au 24 juin
5300 km en vélo de Vancouver à Lévis en
solitaire une moyenne de presque 100 km
par jour à rouler je vais raconter sa
gros défi puisque ça j'ai pas le
physique de cycliste je suis très grasse
je suis très lourd aussi en même temps
c'est pas une course pour moi je me dis
aussi que l'Ukraine résiste devant la
Russie depuis plus d'un an et demi je
suis capable de recourir 5300 km c'est
c'est juste c'est la moindre des choses
il a lancé sa page gophone me et
souhaite que l'argent recueilli serva un
projet précis de reconstruction
pour que je puisse aller le porter à
personne aller faire un projet en
personne
mercredi c'était les derniers
préparatifs 30 kg de bagages à choisir
un itinéraire à finaliser et beaucoup de
logistiques
pour accueillir les nouveaux Ukrainiens
de la région de Québec l'aide pour
chaque étape il fait quelque chose pour
son pays natal et son cœur est là et je
pense tout ce qui se passe en
Ukraine en ce moment c'est le motive ça
me motive aussi la fierté d'une mère et
son stress aussi j'ai peur de tout
comment va l'esprit de maman quand elle
s'imagine que le fils il va traverser
5300 par les montagnes avec les animaux
sauvages avec le transport avec les oh
je suis assez stressée
on est tous derrière toi dans le
voisinage dari et sa famille sont connus
et apprécient dari a déjà recueilli plus
de 13000 dollars pour son projet
c'est de faire ce qu'on peut nous on est
loin mais je pense qu'avec on voit le
grand quart de ces gens des Ukrainiens
qui sont parmi nous ça nous apprend
mieux les connaître aussi c'est une
belle qualité en fait au Québec je suis
vraiment heureux d'être ici et puis pas
de voir mais justifier pourquoi on doit
donner je vais juste dire Ukraine puis
le monde comprenne il agisse déjà Dary
part avec son drapeau de l'Ukraine et
son drapeau du Québec ces deux maisons
dit-il il roulera pour sortir de son
confort nord-américain pour faire sa
part loin des soldats au fronts j'ai
l'impression que depuis le début de la
glace être ukrainien c'est quelque chose
que je mérite et ne pas quelque chose
qui qui est à qui de la naissance pour
moi en fait c'est une façon de mériter
d'être ukrainée ça traversait commence
le premier mais ici jean-Sébastien
Cloutier Radio-Canada Lévis